we're living through a time right now
where people are obsessed with our
president a lot of young people well
people of all ages don't know one day to
the next what this man is gonna do what
he's gonna say you have the perspective
of having been in the news business
pretty much well my entire life you've
been in the news business I've been for
more than 70 years 70 years okay more
than 70 years and you have this
perspective of looking back you have
interviewed every president I believe
since Eisenhower is that right starting
with an hour of interviews every
president okay and you you knew them all
and so I don't know if that gives you a
comprar spective about Donald Trump
President Donald Trump having talked to
so many different presidents does it
give you any sense of some kind of
continuity or has everything gone
haywire well it certainly doesn't give
you a sense of calmness yeah secondly
it's important for us to remember this
is not normal there's never been
anything like this before
it's this kind of president know that we
certainly have had presidents for
example who didn't like the press who've
never had one that steadily out of his
own mouth wade sent an unrelenting
campaign against yes yeah but this is
something brand-new in American history
that's first of all it's not normal
there is a campaign to convince people
and I think particularly young people Oh
what was just way presidencies go
that is not true that the look many
things about the age of Trump will make
the stomach sicker than bad oysters
right that everything from buddy
everything from what he says to the way
he says it for example trying to strike
some equivalency between neo-nazis
neo-nazis yeah and other people who were
trying to protest what the signals he
sent two outfits such as the Ku Klux
Klan yeah another racist outfit I mean
this is unprecedented in American
history and therefore it's a dangerous
time I'm not here to preach that one
reason I wrote what unites us is that
there's so many voices including that
president who trying to exploit the
divisions in the country in the
negativity yeah it's very easy to forget
what unites us
you